if i've got some pent one in and let's
just make sure we name that correctly we
have one two three four five carbons
there's only one chain here and our
double bond is right on the number one
carbon or we'll make this the number one
carbon because it's the closest to the
double bond it's better to start
counting from the left end than the
right end so this is right here pent
pent one
pent one en but in this video what we
want to do is figure out what will
happen if we start with some pent-onein
and to that we add some hydrogen bromide
we add some hydrogen
we add some hydrogen
bromide and to think about this and what
we're going to do this is actually the
very first reaction mechanism we're
going to do but really most of organic
chemistry is all about reaction
mechanisms and it's all about getting a
sense for what is likely to happen or
what is a reasonable reaction we'll
learn a set of rules and hopefully we'll
get an intuition for how things work so
we're doing a reaction mechanism here
reaction
mechanism
reaction mechanism so a good place to
start is to just think about what's
going on at the hydrogen bromide level
and to do that let's look at the
periodic table right here
so we have hydrogen sitting up there and
then we have bromine sitting all the way
to the right over here and we learned in
first year chemistry that things are
more electronegative as you go to the
top right of the periodic table things
get a lot more electronegative
electronegativity grows in that
direction
electro
electronegativity
negativity and just as a refresher
electronegativity just means the
tendency for that atom to hog electrons
so you see bromine over here you see
hydrogen over there bromine is much more
electronegative than hydrogen so in a
hydrogen bromide molecule right here the
bro the bromine part of it is going to
hog the electrons so you're going to
have a partial negative charge you're
going to have a partial negative charge
at the bromine end and you're going to
have a partial positive end at the
hydrogen end
and this is actually so electronegative
that it's reasonable that bromine could
completely steal all of the electrons so
let me draw that so this bond right here
let me make this bond a little bit
bigger
and this is and i'll do the notation
that people usually use when they draw
reaction mechanisms so this bond right
here has two electrons we're saying that
bromine is so much more electronegative
than hydrogen that it could all together
steal hydrogen's electrons it could all
together steal a hydrogen's electrons
and go on to the bromine now if that
happens what will this whole setup look
like well if that happens this whole
setup
will move down a little bit we'll still
have
and i'll just
copy and paste will be useful here so we
still have
our
we still have our
copy
and paste that we still have our
pent-one in
but now in the hydrogen bromide the bond
you could view it as having broken up
because the bromine which is now a
bromide anion will have taken will have
taken the electrons this is what that is
showing so let me draw that and let me
actually clear this out right here let
me erase
this right there
and so this over here will now look like
this the hydrogen
the hydrogen is now just a positive
cation it's just a proton really so you
have hydrogen with a positive charge and
then you have the bromine with a
negative charge now that it's an ion we
would call it bromide
so we would call this
bromide it's sitting on a negative
charge and now what is likely to happen
well i have this i have this alkene here
this penta1
it has this double bond and maybe and in
this double bond you have two electrons
maybe one of these electrons will be
attracted to the hydrogen and then
essentially making making one of these
two carbons i guess you could view it
naked on some level it won't have all of
its electrons anymore so let's do that
let's do that and actually we'll then
think about which carbon is more likely
to be the one that gives its that gives
away its electron so for the sake of for
the sake of this mechanism let's just
say that this carbon right over here
that this carbon right over here that it
is the one that loses its electron so
this bond right here
let me see this bond right here has two
electrons one on this carbon one on that
carbon the carbon on the right loses the
electrons and it goes to the hydrogen
and it goes to the hydrogen it goes to
the hydrogen so then after that happens
what will the setup look like
what will the setup look like so then
we're going to have let me see how
neatly i can draw this let me draw my
let me draw it it's no longer pent-1e
it's something in between now so you
have your original set up carbon
hydrogen
hydrogen
carbon and then you have your ch2
ch2
ch3
this carbon had a hydrogen bond but what
we're saying is that this one of the
electrons here this has two electrons in
it one on this carbon one on this carbon
this bond goes to that hydrogen
so now it will look like this
now it will look like this it went and
bonded to the hydrogen
essentially an electron went from this
carbon right here the carbon on the
right side of the double bond an
electron went from that carbon and went
to the hydrogen now the hydrogen is
neutral but what happens to this carbon
well he gave away an electron
he gave away an electron he had he had
four valence electrons now we'll only
have three so now he will have a
positive charge so you could almost
imagine that the positive charge went
from the hydrogen to the carbon although
it didn't move the electrons are what
move so now this guy is sitting with a
positive charge
this guy is sitting with a positive
charge he would really like access to an
electron and we can't forget that we
have our bromine
we have our bromine sitting there with a
negative charge our bromine sitting
there with a negative charge
our bromine is sitting there with a
negative charge and if we want we can
actually draw its valence electrons
bromine typically
bromine typically has
bromine typically has seven valence
electrons but it stole an electron it
has a negative charge now so now it has
eight valence electrons so we could
actually draw it so it has one two three
four five six seven eight valence
electrons let me draw it over here too
one two three four five six seven eight
valence electrons
it has kind of one extra that's what's
giving us a negative charge this carbon
needs it so why doesn't bromine
why doesn't bromine essentially donate
one of its electrons to the carbon
so why doesn't it donate one of the
electrons to the carbon and then when
that happens what are we going to be
left with
what are we going to be left with this
is one of our final products and in the
next video we'll think about what other
product could we have here so let me
draw this
so bromine
gives an electron forms a bond
essentially with this carbon and then
our molecule will look like this
you have a carbon
let me write a little bit neater carbon
hydrogen
hydrogen you still have that hydrogen
now
in orange i want to make sure we
remember where things came from
and then you have a bond to this carbon
which is bonded now to the bromine
it is bonded now to the bromine
to the bromine and then all of the other
stuff that it was bonded to before you
have a hydrogen and then you have three
another chain of three carbons
another chain
of three
carbons so what we just did is we showed
a reaction mechanism we showed a
plausible way a plausible way to start
with pent one in and hydrogen bromide
and get to
when the two things are mixed together
to get to what is this thing right here
let's name it just for fun what is this
thing right here we still have one two
three four five carbons it's now an
alkane there are no double bonds here so
we're dealing with pentane
so this is pentane
pentane and it has one group on the
chain it has this bromo group right
there we want to start numbering closest
to that group so that's one two
three four five carbon so this is two
bromopentane
two
bromo
two bromopentane so by adding the
addition of hydrogen bromide to pent
five e sorry pent one en to pent one e
we were able to come up with a reaction
mechanism to get to two bromo pentane